Richard claims that he could take all
those pumpkin beers pour a little bit in
his [ __ ] and he would be able to tell
you all seven beers he just wants to
show you his ass the smell of ass and
beer together can't be better hey boys
Richard who is administering the beer JD
I'm JD doe yeah he's my butt tender
I didn't by the way I didn't have a
chance to clear my throat this morning
huh in the chamber so the beer might
come bubbling back up JD didn't you have
to pour the last time and you were kind
of resistant to that because he stinks
so bad I just say it's funny it's weird
he's got a weird [ __ ] it looks like
there's two holes there's this [ __ ]
and then like it looks like there might
be a little another little hole there he
knows way too much about my ass I had to
do this twice maybe one is his drinking
hole so what are we doing here you're
gonna take different pumpkin beers and
then yeah I'd call out the brand name
and by the way I'm not claiming that
I've never done this before so I don't
know that I'm gonna be great I just want
to try there are five cups of beer there
marked on the bottom so Richard can't
possibly tell can they give me the
different types of beer just so I know
so I can say don't tell them what type
of beer it is but wait don't look
Richard while Richards getting naked on
the ground I could tell you that we have
a rogue farms pumpkin patch fisherman's
a pumpkin stout woodchuck hard cider and
by the way mix up the orders with you
guys I gotta tell you what to do go
ahead pumpkin ale my legs I want you to
see this he's got a giant pink ball bag
I just wanted to let you know that
certain people around here concerned
that he had a lot to drink last night
Oh so be careful about how much you
don't power fine no I'm fine all right
let's do the first one JD get over here
JD get to it JD just do it just pour a
little Bo Garry pull my legs back a
little there we go all right okay it's
been poured in loving taste it that's a
tough one to tell I would guess the
Smuttynose
is such money no it is not
you want a little more my ass a little
more ox or a little more is whole is
breathing no holy [ __ ] the beer gets in
there and then he like sucks it in Wow
good for you Richard you find this
finally found something you're good at
I like it Robin so excited ease off Mike
at the pump King the Imperial how did
you know that it tastes like a high
alcohol beer kind of give him one more
by the way Gary I I'm not getting closer
to it I didn't mean I didn't poop this
morning it got in okay and let me switch
it around is that is that the stout no
it is not go in his [ __ ] but there's
a little pool that gets in there and he
sucks that in yeah I've done this before
I know how to give flex my his head is
about to explode is that the cider yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
can we just cleaning it install this in
the garbage I'll keep that towel that's
a good towel of it